[Musique]
si agréable pour les doubler en
bicyclette et de nouveaux moteurs
parce que la situation du sort il ya pas
longtemps que vous avez 80 89 ans oui
l'interné quel effet ça vous fait d'être
1-1 entre 90 les jeunes familles ça
continue tout pareil oui c'est pas
dangereux de monter à l'échelle comme
quand vous faites là vinci où il fait de
même attention je peux le faire je le
fais est ce que vous payez la ccl
commencer béchir du sureau wii dont elle
avait les yeux bleus les chaudes
il faut briller le bouillon et après ça
fait du bien ah ben si ça peut pas une
pierre je ferais pas ça fait lourd quand
même un une brouettée de voix lors des
casses h à montayral échelle
transportait du bois à 89 en inde à
merveille vous ne reculer devant rien
comment appelez-vous ça j'ai plein
d'ambition et ça voilà celui qui n'a pas
l'ambition il ne fait rien trouvé que
les jeunes de maintenant n'ont pas trop
en usine il faut bien qu'ils fassent le
travail
il faut dire que pour gagner sa vie
vous suivez un peu ce qui est ce qu'on
fait maintenant là les gens qui vont
dans la lune ça ne m'intéresse pas non
ovi du mans est que nul main on vous
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de rester
jeune
il ya un secret moi je voyage aussi bien
dans le flou et comme par l'eau je
voyage tout le temps alors il ya des
bonnes femmes quand il fait frais chez
eux
pis quand elles sortent ya les vrais
tombé malade sur la saisie dans l'iss
comme je le disais hiberner je voyage
toujours mais c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait
puis voilà
[Musique]